Мешканка Маріуполя Олена Молочек не вважає себе панікеркою,
але зізнається: після оголошення воєнного стану
очікувала, що місто вмить заполонять військові,
буде введено комендантську годину,
а люди почнуть у паніці бігати в пошуках продуктів і води.
Так само, як у 2014-му та 2015-му, коли
з боку так званої "ДНР" обстрілювали Маріуполь.
- Бачила, як усе згрібали з полиць.
Олена рада, що поки немає ані комендантської години,
ані проблем з продуктами, зважаючи на вміст
усіх цих полиць. Є хліб. Є сірники. І сіль теж є.
- Небагато. Але є. Краще, ніж нічого.
Олена не збирається робити великі запаси провіанту.
Зі своїм досвідом життя в місті на лінії фронту вона розуміє,
що в разі обстрілів треба з мінімумом речей
швидко тікати подалі на машині, тож кожного дня
моніторить ситуацію на АЗС. Наразі бензин є і ціни,
незважаючи на очікування, не підскочили.
Городяни, з якими DW поспілкувалася на вулицях Маріуполя,
повідомили, що їх підприємства працюють у звичайному режимі.
Проблем із виплатою зарплат наразі немає.
Немає й черг біля банкоматів.
У роботі міського транспорту та комунальних служб
якихось збоїв не було. Зовні в Маріуполі наче нічого не змінилося,
та й запровадження воєнного стану
після чотирьох років життя на лінії фронту тут не сприймають як щось надзвичайне.
- Не бачу паніки, тому що все як було, так і залишилося.
- Більше стало машин поліції. Все. Більше нічого не помітила.
Із продуктами в нас не буде проблем абсолютно.
- Я - голова кооперативу. За мною колектив.
Будемо слухати, що уряд казатиме. То й будемо робити, щоб нічого в нас не змінилося.
- Хай все лишається, як було. Ми вже до всього звикли.
Навряд чи буде так, як було, вважає координатор ГО
"Самооборона Маріуполя" Дмитро Шульга.
На його переконання, напад і захоплення
українських катерів в Азовському морі свідчать про
новий, більш серйозний рівень небезпеки насамперед для Маріуполя.
Командира "Cамооборони" дуже непокоять настрої в місті.
- Багато хто настільки розслаблений…
Ось це страшне слово: звикання до стану напруги,
коли люди звикають в цьому стані знаходитися.
Мовляв, ну падають і падають десь там снаряди,
ну вибухають, але ж не долітають. Ось це дуже небезпечно.
Самоборонівці закликають населення
не втрачати зв'язок із реальністю і заздалегідь готуватися:
дістати "тривожні" валізи, наповнити аптечки,
змусити чиновників знову перевірити бомбосховища
та взагалі якось інформувати людей про стан речей.
Олена постійно моніторить сайти міськради, уряду,
місцевих ЗМІ, соціальні мережі, аби знайти
відповідь на запитання: наскільки ж небезпечно
знаходитися в Маріуполі і що робити населенню
в разі ескалації. Чітких відповідей не знаходить.
із досвіду 2014-го і 2015-го років вона знає, що може і не знайти.
На випадок потужних артилерійських обстрілів
її родина підготувалася ще чотири роки тому.
- Тут ми все залізом укріпляли.
Ось, бачите, перегородки. Вентиляція є. Все як слід.
Укомплектовувати сховище по-новому Олена вже почала.
Унизу є вода, відро для туалету. І ось тепер і ковдра.
- У такому підвалі, своєрідному міні-бункері,
можуть бути одночасно троє людей.
Тут можна тримати запас води і їжі на місяць,
але довго тут не всидиш,
бо може бути дуже холодно.
Олена сподівається, що Маріуполю вдасться
уникнути активних бойових дій і тут сидіти не доведеться.
Та навіть якщо її сподівання справдяться,
жінка сумнівається, що її життя буде стабільним,
адже вона вже зараз не може заробляти в Маріуполі своїм бізнесом - виступати з вогняним шоу.
Після запровадження воєнного стану такі шоу вже недоречні.
Наразі її групі скасували більшість замовлень на новорічні свята.
- Усі хочуть зберегти готівку, щоб можна було
швидко зірватися й поїхати в разі евакуації.
Олена з чоловіком і п’ятирічним сином
вже серйозно думають про переїзд в якусь із країн Європи.
На думку Олени, якщо Україні не допоможуть
міжнародні партнери з реальним захистом морських кордонів,
на азовському узбережжі буде ще довго неспокійно.